George Brett was a was the man he was a
great baseball player on the Kansas City
Royals
there is leaked video and audio of him
this guy let me just this guy let me
just start before I even play it this is
the most this is more than hitting a
Grand Slam more than shagging fly balls
more than eating sunflower seeds waiting
on the on-deck circle this right here
this three minutes is the most baseball
thing that has ever happened
so he's stretching so now the stretch oh
he farts I didn't realize this but
that's what he says you hear that fart
Wow okay so he farts stretching next to
a player farted
not even I farted do you know how limit
a some the ego you have to have on you
to fart and then say farted okay so now
the younger players like okay and he's
just stretching and he says I did I've
had a great meal just a great [ __ ]
meal I had to go a bathroom so bad the
Karim
[ __ ] [ __ ] my pants I'm good twice a
year for that what was the last time you
[ __ ] your pants yeah been a while I was
in Vegas a couple years ago just honest
I got true story I mean I just I want to
set the Bellagio one over the Mirage for
dinner I met some friends of mine over
there we went to Kokomo some great
little raw steak house the guy brings
out some fresh crab legs
you guys bring I'm eating them then we
go play gamble a little bit I have a tee
time early in the morning so I said look
I got to get going I'm walking back to
the hotel I get three-quarters the way
out of the lobby and all of a sudden I
go oh [ __ ] and I'm standing here like
this I got my butt pinched so [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] I can't move all of a sudden you
know felt all right I want just like
this oh yeah you think
take off my leather jacket I'm just
standing there and it's just running
down I got jeans on black bucks
then I'm standing outside my cell phone
I call the guy I said Larry you won't
believe this I'm standing outside the
[ __ ] Bellagio I can't move I got [ __ ]
everywhere I [ __ ] all over myself and
Larry's about a 48 waist so he brings me
over a pair of pants and some towels and
some towels and so he then he comes over
and he meets me where I'm Stella where
I'm standing he finds the closest
bathroom when you go up the escalator go
into the [ __ ] I can't get in the
elevator so so he goes in he finds the
closest bathroom in a lobby of the hotel
and then I get in the escalator and he
kind of sounds like he dropped something
so no one gets behind me dude you know
this I go in there he goes and gets the
towel are the guys will throws it over
the [ __ ] the guy who's talking to him
is walking away he's following him leave
my shoes let my shoes my pants
everything right there the towels right
there in the stall and I'm walking
barefoot with my shirt and his pants
that are 48 ways through the
ah be like this midnight they're all
walking away perfect double taper should
I've ever had in my life
wait for it wait for it true story wait
for it wait for it first of all should
know imagine wearing no socks and a
leather jacket should my pants outside
that's who deserves to [ __ ] their pants
no Bellagio and the early tee time
nothing is more baseball than playing
golf in the morning so it's just it's
before the game he's stretching he
shouldn't be he's just why do the
managers stretch and wear the uniform
hey guy sad there's the part by the way
he's stretching in front of a guy the
guys faces in his ass and he farted he
says forty and that's so such a boss
move dude
[Music]
dude also you don't have to say double
tapered [ __ ] the first end is always
tapered because it's common out it's the
second part that is sometimes not
tapered you know perfect double taper
[ __ ] Wow how baseball is it you got to
watch this George Brett [ __ ] thank
God it's so funny man
[Music]